Hello!
Today I come to give you my opinion with ilerna,
more specifically with ilerna online.
I have done four training cycles with ilerna,
one,
a medium grade that was totally face-to-face,
second one grade higher
which was half face-to-face
and then I went overboard and finished it off remotely,
and already two degrees higher
which was completely at a distance,
completely online.
These degrees was
first the middle grade of nursing assistant,
then the degree of oral hygiene,
that I started in person and went overboard
for personal and work reasons,
and second eh social integration.
I did the top grade first
and the higher grade of early childhood education.
I used to combine all this with my personal life.
and with working life,
that always made a full day.
Pros,
online air day.
payment facilities,
you can finance it
and many times
I would fuck
that you finance it without having to pay interest.
If you take it in advance
give you a twenty percent discount.
Career in some companies you work for
or at least when I started um
your company was giving a discount.
There was an agreement that gave you a discount
and I did catch it once,
so it was very good.
More pros,
facilities when studying,
since they record,
classes are postponed
and you can see them whenever you want.
They have
my own books that I used to buy at the beginning very much.
very very excited and all,
but in the end,
I stopped buying them
because between the notes I was taking and everything,
because I could do it without the book,
but this depends on each other.
More pros there are is that there are facilities to contact eh
tutors,
with teachers,
resolve doubts.
In my general opinion
online herna is quite affordable,
to be able to take you out
the degrees you want.
I don't want to say get it as a gift
because they obviously don't give it to you as a gift,
you have to make an effort and work it out,
but I think it is quite painful and gives you help.
that you may not get them elsewhere.
I can't talk about other places because I haven't been,
but for example in elerna online
apart from leaving your classes recorded
and be able to see them when you want,
is continuous,
is continuous evaluation,
you have activities that also help you to review
and activities
eh.
In theory
you have to study and do the activities
to see if you fail or not,
but let's see if you do the activities without studying,
you can see the books,
notes and such
and it is quite painful
approve the activities section as well.
Then is it essential to take exams before exams?
eh?
They give you three models from previous exams,
that many times
enter
some of the answers from previous exams,
so you know a question
and
puts three models from previous exams
with the answers so that we can practice
and there is also a week-long question round.
Also when it makes
record the classes you can ask in the chat room.
The truth is that in my opinion
is quite painful.
I really enjoyed the experience
and I have been very comfortable and very happy.
And the truth is that it has served me well.
Cons,
the biggest cons that we all know
and and sometimes
that's why it's hard for us to start studying
with herna online
is the price,
because it is a price that is not like the public price,
is more expensive,
but
at the end of the day is what needs to be paid and
prices will not go down,
so if you want to study that you have to pay.
But the good thing is that
because in my case they did interest-free financing,
but it is expensive and it is money.
Another con,
In my case,
what made me very angry is that I,
as I have told you,
I did quite a few cycles
and I validated some things.
I paid the entire,
I paid for the entire course
if it was one hundred and ninety-nine euros per course,
I would pay these one hundred and ninety-nine euros
because it did not give me the option to hang up
and
and they said that I knew how to pay for the subjects anyway.
and you hung up.
Okay,
I paid and validated subjects
without any problem,
but then I found out that
if you had already studied previously in ilerna,
You don't have to pay for both face-to-face and online,
do you?
The course to enrich it is free of charge
because Ilerna's own people have the file and do not
to look for it and such,
In other words,
bonuses are free of charge.
It made me very angry
because I paid a lot of money I could have saved
and at no time will we have specified
in ilerna online.
This from people who knew and said it later,
but I didn't put it on ilerna's page.
I did talk to the people at ilerna online.
and they told me they were sorry,
but well,
I already knew it for next few times.
and I spent a lot of money when it wasn't necessary.
In other words,
you should know that if you come from ilerna
face-to-face or sleepless online,
for example,
if you do two degrees in ilerna,
if you want to show off it is free,
free eh,
call and such.
Now that I was saying the calling thing,
s,
call.
Sometimes you have a question about exams,
guys,
flame, flame,
flame, flame
and they don't catch it because they are supermegahiper collapsed.
In the e-mail they answer more,
at least my experience,
but that sometimes
eh cost was to contact them,
I haven't told you before,
but
topic Examination tests.
You have the regular exam,
then you did the recovery
that you could find in the price of the subject.
and then I don't know if I remember
that will not happen to you because you will
approve everything at the first time,
but if you do not approve the first and the second,
then
Hey,
you were paying.
I don't know if it was,
you were paying a little.
Well, a little,
you paid less than the full course
fifty euros I think it was
and you had another chance of the exam
without having to do everything again
eh the subject.
By the way,
if you fail one unit,
if you fail a module of a subject
a formative unit of five,
you are only going to recovery with that training unit,
not of five o'clock or of the subject
also.
I
who worked
there were many facilities for taking the exam.
because you could put the day you wanted
the schedule that was going well for you.
They do exams on Saturdays and Sundays,
so it was quite easy to combine it with
with personal life or with the
or with the separate work.
In many pages test exams are hung.
In my case this is also important.
In my case in the cycles I did eh,
the exams were test-type,
there were none for development.
I don't know if maybe
in the IT sector
or in another branch is to be developed,
but in the ones I did
it was all a test type,
so I am super happy with herna online.
I did great
so that I could get the degrees I wanted to get out of them.
and combine it with work life
and with personal life
and
has generally been a very good option.
Yes,
money has had to be paid,
but
I really think it's worth it
because it gives you a lot of facilities in every way.
Well,
I've felt like
if it were face-to-face classes,
almost almost without partners,
but
from the teaching side eh?
They were very close,
you could talk to them,
solve doubts.
I really enjoyed the experience.
Another good thing,
sorry before I forget,
I think it is for example in the en.
In these cycles that I have done
there was no such thing as group work
because I have heard that
elsewhere they command a lot of group work,
even if it is a long- cycle,
of course,
if it is a long- cycle
you find it difficult to meet other people
to do a job.
In the case of ilerna online no,
it's all your own work,
you do not have to do group work